un cratère en plein centre de cramât
tort sq plusieurs immeubles ont été
touchées ainsi que des voitures d'après
les autorités locales
l'explosion très violente aurait fait
une dizaine de blessés et causé la mort
d'au moins une personne
il ya eu une énorme explosion ma femme
et moi étions assis dans le salon quand
tout d'un coup tout s'est mis à voler
elle s'est jetée sur le sol et a
commencé à ramper on n'a même pas
entendu l'obus arrivé je ne sais pas
vraiment ce qu'il s'est passé mais
l'explosion était telle qu'elle a
soufflé toutes les vitres après
severodonetsk lsi shank cramatte or ce
qu est la nouvelle cible de l'armée
russe dans le donbass un peu plus au
nord à re kif la deuxième ville du pays
a été visé par de nouveaux bombardements
une fois encore les victimes sont des
civils cet homme sous le choc pleure la
mort d'un proche tué par un éclat d'obus
dans toute la région ceux qui le peuvent
encore prennent la route de l'ouest
cette femme de 91 ans a dû quitter sa
ville d'oslo viande ce qu en catastrophe
il n'y a plus d'eau plus de gaz
et on ne peut même pas transporter de
l'eau dans des bidons puisqu'il n'y a
plus d'eau potable nulle part
on ne peut pas non plus sortir à cause
des bombardements incessants
ces femmes il laisse derrière elle toute
une vie sans certitude de pouvoir
revenir un jour